monsieur le président dragué chers
collègues
effectivement les questions de lutte
contre les changements climatiques nous
discutons aujourd'hui revêtent une
importance particulière
particulièrement importante dans la
mesure où elle concerne chacun d'entre
nous la russie comme les autres pays
ressent en elles mêmes les conséquences
négatives de ce réchauffement
climatique le problème de l'érosion des
sols nous sommes préoccupés aussi par la
disparition
de la merzlota
et cela concerne une grande partie de
nos territoires et la température
moyenne annuelle augmente
plus vite que la température moyenne
dans le monde c'est à dire que de
deux fois et demie plus vite et depuis
10 ans en particulier et cela concerne
aussi les terres arctiques et notre pays
est très active et lancent des
initiatives
des initiatives à l'international pour
maintenir une situation normale et nous
assurons l'ensemble de nos
responsabilités internationales
nous menons une politique de réduction
des rejets dans l'air les réduire
l'effet de serre et nous cherchons à
trouver des solutions pour
moderniser le secteur énergétique
réduire les effets des rejets dans l'air
et la russie à un rythme régulier
travail sur les énergies renouvelables
et la partie de l'énergie provenant
d'autres sources par exemple
hydroélectrique nucléaire solaire
dépasse 40% et contenus du gaz naturel
qui est disponible
qui parmi les hydrocarbures et le moins
polluant on est on a quand même un taux
intéressant et selon les appréciations
des experts internationaux la russie
bien engagée dans la décarbonisation
c'est dernière ces vingt dernières
années
le taux
des dettes jules se réduit chaque année
de 2 27% et c'est même meilleure que
dans certains pays du g7 nous avons pris
la décision
de nous avons pris la décision de lancer
un certain nombre de projets en
justement en matière d
énergie plus efficace pour l'économie
et nous avons l'objectif de la
neutralité carbone pour 2060 et c'est
une obligation que nous engageons à
respecter et c'est pas seulement que
nous cherchons à obtenir cette
neutralité mais dans les trois
prochaines décennies
nous voulons absolument réduire
cette
l'effet de serre pour que nous ayons un
tome même meilleure que dans la zone
européenne et nous espérons que nous
pourrons travailler avec l'ensemble de
nos partenaires à long terme pour mettre
en oeuvre en tant que priorité cette
orientation et
en
d'étudiants différents types de
génération
aujourd'hui l'énergie solaire par
exemple
d'après les données scientifiques
et plus et quatre fois plus importantes
que l'énergie nucléaire
donc il s'agit de soutenir ici les
projets écologiques les plus efficaces
et les experts ont pu établir justement
un classement des projets les plus
efficaces visant à réduire les effets
l'effet de serre
et ce classement je comprends de projet
comprend aussi des projets de maintien
des forêts en russie et en amérique
latine et ils sont même plus efficace
par exemple que certains projets en
énergies renouvelables je souligne aussi
que la résolution du problème du
réchauffement
mondial ii ne concerne pas seulement le
problème des roja dans la il y a aussi
les effets de les gaz à effet de serre
qui doivent être réduits et là il ya un
certain nombre de potentiel à développer
il ya aussi le potentiel des forêts des
la nature pour que nous ayons donc un
potentiel qu'ils puissent être mises en
valeur
donc cette question de gestion des
forêts est aussi une orientation qui est
développée chez nous et nous cherchons à
mettre en place de nouvelles
agrotechnologie
et là encore il ya des perspectives de
coopération internationale pour des
décennies
dans l'avenir et c'est un effort mondial
qui peut être fait et nous supposons que
dans la mise en oeuvre de ces
initiatives
le
g20 doit justement donner des
orientations et donner une impulsion en
toute transparence
et ces règles doivent s'appuyer sur la
reconnaissance mutuelle des modèles
technologiques qui ont été recherchées
pour la réduction des effets de serre il
s'agit donc je cette lutte complexe et
généralisées contre le réchauffement
climatique qui doit se faire tout en
assurant une croissance économique une
amélioration du niveau de vie de la
population je vous remercie pour votre
attention